I have a very I've had a very skittish
relationship with home going back to
when I was diagnosed with MS I didn't
believe in the idea of hope for a long
time
frankly I thought it was for weak people
you know I thought that the strength
personal strength and perseverance could
replace hope and when I was at the
Vatican I met with a lot of doctors and
scientists who were already doing stem
cell therapy and I was really quite
taken I mean I was quite surprised I
always saw a sort of Panay had a
futuristic view of stem cell therapy I
thought it was sounded great but it was
down the road and I had this flash of
hope that I had never felt before
and and it really washed over ma'am and
it was quite uh quite astonishing to me
and frankly having met all these people
I was determined to find somebody to
help me and one of the people on my
panel was a neurologist named that would
Siddiq it was a big MS guy in in New
York and he invited me to come see him
when when I got back to New York and I
really had in my head and by the way he
casually mentioned that he an
application into the FDA and I got was
really interested and when the FDA
approves the trial which had taken years
of lobbying to make happen he told me
that I was going to be the first one he
treated not for any reason except that
uh an unusual presentation of the
disease because it's on one side
my body most people something both sides
so it was much easier to chart progress
of the lack of progress with me so I was
literally the first person in the world
to be tried it treated with this
specific kind of cell was gone as in
kind of cells which are big blank stem
cells and that was the beginning of
triumph but I started writing at that
point and I realized that I would I had
an attitude about hope it was changing
it was in flux and I thought the search
for hope would be a good look because I
think us finding hope for me it was a
journey you know and I'm look my head's
are not my head is not in the clouds
I'm not whistling Dixie and skipping
down the street on the other hand I
think that my bearing and my demeanor
have changed I think I'm a brighter
person not a smarter person but a more
valuable person I think that I think my
state of mind has changed you know and
hope though hope and optimism are
different how can breed optimism and I
think I'm more optimistic about changing
my life that I have been there no look I
mean life is a journey so for the
healthy in the SEC we don't know the
destination and so I there are no
predictions here for me or for anybody
else but I feel I just feel better about
myself and better about my prospects for
the future since I've been writing this
book
because I've been sick for with various
things at various times you know I've
seen a lot of clergy in very much and
passing I talk to them because they're
interesting people I talk to rabbis and
priests and ministers and Imams and them
they all sell hope and they're very
well-intentioned
but they're very doctrinal about how you
know they I'm much more of this belief
that it's organic you know that it to
whatever extent it exists it's inside of
us and I think we just go where it takes
us
and I I just don't think you can
legislate hope on the other hand I do
think that you can open yourself up
which is what I did I mean my mind was
closed and locked and I had turn away
the key when it came to hope but then it
changed and and once I began the book it
it really was a very personal inquiry
and I learned a lot about where I stood
on help and so I'm very glad that I've
done
[Music]